hello Vsauce today we've got a new
episode of up all night where I show off
my favorite geeky and techie pranks
first just in time for April Fool's Day
we've got two Wiggly calm now be careful
because when you go there it causes your
browser window to do this to stop it
just press ctrl W on a PC or command W
on a Mac for a better scare there's the
infamous blue screen of death
screensaver for you Mac users out there
no worries you can grab a kernel panic
screensaver that's even animated to
scroll down like the real thing for less
terror and more fun let's talk
JavaScript skater haha one showed me
this and it blew my mind
by copying and pasting code number one
from this video's description in your
address bar you can actually play the
game asteroids against whatever website
you're on or turn up the brooding by
using code number to this code inverts
color so you can show off your exclusive
access to youtube black or hate Facebook
Gogh if you prefer blue and red use code
number three to make a page full of
images work with 3d blue and red glasses
and by the way you can reset all of this
stuff by just pressing refresh now
here's something actually useful a
project from Mark Beasley that creates a
snowstorm out of tweets containing the
word you put after the equal sign for
instance here's one where you can see
people talking about Vsauce Beasley
doesn't stop there this site records and
broadcasts the locations of the cursor
of everyone on it so hearing him this
morning it was just me and my friend in
the other room but go there now I'll be
there I'll be the one making little V's
for Vsauce
let's make automatic art this site takes
the title you give your work and then
searches Google Images for a number of
pics and then randomly edits crops and
layers each time you click create it
generates a new random design based on
the words you put in the title speaking
of Google Image Search here is its
opposite 10 i com allows you to enter an
image and then find out where else on
the web that image is it's a great way
to find larger versions
or to find out whose copy now a
submission from crazy taco a 3d video
but like really you can try it out by
following the link in the description
and while watching the video click and
drag your mouse to move around so that
the camera is pretty much your head I've
got a new episode of Luke coming out
tomorrow so hold on to your noses
subscribe to Vsauce for more and you
haven't yet click any of these to watch
other pranks and tricks from previous
episodes of up all night oh and by the
way thanks for watching
you